hey everyone we're back here again at
the e3 2016 GameSpot war room and I'm
Scott Butterworth this is tomorrow
saying we're gonna talk to you this time
about Ghost Recon wildlands which we
finally got a chance to play earlier
today it's more how did you feel about
our experience with the game not too
great and left me wanting a lot I think
a big issue we have is that it doesn't
seem to have very many mechanics you
know it's it's a pre-alpha game and we
should stress that but when you go into
a pre-alpha game you kind of want there
to be a core loop that entreats you or
gets it soak into you and at the moment
the only kind of experience was a very
bare-bones more player shooter right
things like you know missing textures or
the graphics not being 100% perfect so
like that's kind of forgivable in an
alpha build but it's a little worrying
when the most advanced mechanic in a
game is the ability to go prone like
yeah there really wasn't much to just
the basic moment-to-moment mechanics of
the game I mean you can pop a flying
drone that will automatically mark
enemies for you but that's really the
only tool in your tool belt that isn't
just like shooting dudes I mean yes I
mean tell us a little bit about the
mission that we we went on the mission
we went on it's obviously wildlands
takes place in this vast up in the world
and it was huge a lot of its barren but
like that's the whole schtick it's like
you get this massive world then you go
from the vehicles there loads of
vehicles you use it to get around so we
started off in on like a mountain top
area and infiltrated a little village
town or something like that and there
was one guy we need to capture and grab
some Intel awesome he was surrounded by
three Goonies and there was four of us
playing and we each highlighted one of
the enemies to take out on the count of
three we did that the guy bolted didn't
go very far was like the shortest chase
ever and he hit in the most illogical
places no enemies to help him out no
fortifications so we just kind of rolled
in there and grabbed him and interrogate
him and then jumped in the chopper and
off we went and that was kind of like a
short mission that was supposed to
introduce us but I felt like I didn't it
didn't wasn't impactful anyway I didn't
enjoy the shooting I don't think there
was it was challenging me to be tactical
I was just told by the Ruby
self-represented to be tactical and I
was like well yeah why would I ever do
that if I'm
if these guys I'm not really putting up
much of an effort that we're standing in
the open like there's no reason for me
to be strategic about anything as you
pointed at the time the Ghost Recon name
sort of carries with it a little bit
away in certain expectations of the kind
of gameplay the that comes along with
that name
well yeah none of that was really in the
game so far and even the core shooting
was you know not super satisfying at the
moment it all felt pretty light
I remember one point getting shot and
just not even really feeling threatened
is just feeling confused where like
where am I even getting shot from yeah
there was no real tension to the to the
moments moment gameplay yeah and it's
surprising because they have that
something they've worked out and a lot
of the other game this is a company that
shares a lot of their ideas throughout
their teams and projects so it's not
like we saw anything from the division
in here division has you know timber and
kind of the base Condor and it's got a
fork right has a huge world systemic
that people can you know explore and
this wildlife and like to interact with
but this has none of that it's a very
very very basic third-person shooter it
doesn't even have cousin mechanics and
that's the basics of strategy yeah I
mean certain certain parts were worked
well I mean we did have this sequence
where we were flying around a chopper
shooting chainguns but even then it was
difficult to tell what kind of attack we
were really having on the world and sure
like things weren't exploding there was
none of that feedback you couldn't see
like the enemy who of thinning out or
anything it just felt like we were
pummeling this area of full of bullets
and not doing much yeah and I really see
much a result in any way and I mean
again to emphasize this to sin alpha
build so that there's plenty of time for
the game to improve but it is a little
disappointing after you know this full
year of waiting after having learned
about the game last year there wasn't
kind of more impact to what we saw today
so with any luck the game will improve
over the coming months but for now it's
it's not living up to the expectations
we had coming out of last year's e3 but
that said we have plenty more games to
show you this week so please the ground
games Broadcom with plenty more to cover
here at e3 2016
you